[Music]
the third trailer for Avengers endgame
has just dropped and it's the best look
at the film that we've had yet it's
filled with highlights of what's to come
and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the one-shot there will of
course be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything about the
film then I highly suggest that you turn
off now without the way I'm definition
and this is the channel where we explain
it so you don't have to unlike the other
trailers this one is definitely a full
attack on Thanos there has been rumors
that initially the film begins with the
Avengers going to face him head-on and
being beaten before attempting to
time-travel as another way to get rid of
him this seems to cement that theory
with the Avengers flying through space
to tackle him and even admitting that
they are going in very short-handed
there are a wealth of shots that
showcase the Avengers up against the
wall this time but it's not all bleak
nebula holds hands with rocket which
confirms that perhaps he rescues them
and Tony reunites with Pepper sape on
earth Hawkeye too has a sick new sleeve
and it appears that everyone is ready to
kick some ass so they take the
guardianship which is how Tony and
nebula returned to earth and take the
fight directly to Thanos himself there
are no white quantum suits in this first
look so once again this confirms that
time travel is only used after they are
beaten we then get the money shot of
Danis after he states that they could
not live with their own failure and that
this has brought them back to him we
then see the Avengers face him head-on
and it's a kick-ass moment that really
gets you hugged by the movie so
hopefully this is the first hour of the
film with the heroes being defeated once
more and having to find a way around it
I can definitely see this going ahead
and it seems like all the rumors about
this are true
if you have another theory then make
sure you let me know in the comments
below and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the recent Twilight
Zone series which will be linked at the
end this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]